you never never fight out here
we could build spacecraft build rockets
go to this place but when we got there
nothing could be more descriptive than
the word desolation we leave it we gave
it God willing
[Music]
Earthrise as we've never seen it the
stunning high-definition images are from
one of the most sophisticated spacecraft
ever built
Kaguya circles the moon at around 60
miles above ground beaming that glorious
pictures of the lunar surface
that satellite has improved our
understanding our definition just what
the surface of the moon really looks
like and and it ought to stir the
imagination in any human being
the massive three-ton Kaguya allows us
to explore the many phases of the moon
like this hallowed ground the Sea of
Tranquility
you are confirmed gold bourbon
[Music]
at one of their plan
one
[Music]
Kaguya also exposes the elusive dark
side of the moon with its jagged terrain
and sheds new light of the black lava
flows of ancient volcanoes landscapes
that if intrigued scientists since
Apollo 17 left this site in 1972
[Music]
we see an HD clarity where Earth's last
official tourists roamed the moon until
Russia's little known Luna Cod Rover
which continues to inspire the next
generation of robotic explorers
[Music]
Kaguya is greatest contribution is its
ability to provide three-dimensional
mapping the images give us an
unprecedented view of the moon as if we
are really there
[Music]
helping scientists plan for our next
visit one that will become permanent
t-minus 15 seconds guidance is internal
in the case of our habitat work we're
asked to provide housing a place to live
for four crew members initially that
would be for 14 days at a time
evolving to where they could stay for as
long as 180 days
so our job here is to build machines
that help humans explore space whether
they're spacecraft
whether they're Rovers that can take the
crew across the lunar surface
[Music]
in this century this time in human
history our world is not just the earth
our world is now expanding for the first
time ever across the solar system
and out into the universe and the moon
is that first step
you